inside ukraine there are thousands of
foreign volunteers fighting on the front
lines some of them even have their
twitter profiles where they provide
updates on what they're up to usually
with photos and videos i myself started
following a few of them early on like
rape rawlings and james vasquez it's all
rochelle
nice
this guy needs a helmet but there was
another foreign fighter from the faraway
land of canada canadian ukrainian
volunteer at first glance his page
appeared to be there a quote unquote
average for a volunteer he would often
post frontline news and also pictures
and videos of his exploits but his posts
felt a bit strange compared to other
such pages something was off and
initially i couldn't quite tell what it
was mike filled me in on the rats in the
cellar their anguish sustains me the
more they squirm the harder i get okay
something's definitely up with this guy
this sounds less like a professional
soldier and more like an edgy 12 year
old commenting on their linking park
song on youtube and otherwise his post
just read strangely over the top as if
he is just putting up a carefully
choreographed charade and pretending to
be a volunteer soldier in ukraine from
the safety of his canadian home as if he
is just a larper enter twitter user kung
flu panda who based on canadian
ukrainian volunteers posted photos made
a couple of interesting discoveries his
profile is linked below let's take a
look after rewards from today's sponsor
atlas vpn atlas vpn offers a service
that encrypts your data and hides your
virtual location from crying eyes it
helps you protect your privacy and
allows you to bypass those ever annoying
region locks with atlas vpn you'll be
able to unlock all that content locked
away from you arbitrarily only based on
your location like on netflix and other
streaming platforms all you need to do
is open the app pick a server and that's
it atlas vpn also includes a breach
scanner function able to tell you if
there are any data leaks associated with
a given email address atlas vpn also
allows you to block unwanted trackers
from websites with their new tracker
blocker feature all you need to do is
flip the switch right now atlas vpn is
running a summer sale for their 3-year
plan for just 199 per month with one
extra month for free using the code adam
something and of course with a 30 day
money back guarantee the link is in the
description atlas of course runs both on
desktop and mobile and is compatible
across all well-known operating systems
protect your privacy and don't let
region blocks stop you take advantage of
this discount today by clicking the link
in the description thank you for
checking out atlas vpn ads like this
helps support what i do and now back to
the video
on one of cuv's usual boomer selfies two
of his ak magazines are visible but just
what kind of mags are those is it
possible to determine thankfully ak-47
magazines are infected by a wide variety
of countries each with specific unique
details is it a yugoslavian mag its ribs
are short and don't extend all the way
till the depression the ribs on cov's
mag do no match is it a chinese mag both
ribs look about the same but wait cuv's
magazine has his spine while the chinese
mag is flat no match but thankfully kung
flu panda dug deeper and managed to find
the exact type cuv is using it's this
one so what type of magazine is this as
it turns out it's the rare and famous
ak-47 magazine replica excellent for
theater and film productions get yours
today for just 27.50 and as kung-fu
panda noticed when posting a carefully
choreographed picture with his magazines
canadian ukrainian volunteer made sure
to hide the top of the magazines so we
won't notice that a they're empty and b
inert and unable to take cartridges even
if he had any this leads us to
here we have a picture of cuv's gun
looks like an ordinary rifle nothing to
see here or is there let's take a closer
look first his optics based on the
markings it's a hidden red dot reflex
side with picatinny rail mounts
available on amazon for just 35.99 okay
oh but this suppressor looks neat i
wonder what type this is well turns out
it's a kac qdc cqb
airsoft dummy suppressor for the great
price of 94.99 how about that handguard
a cyma full metal aks47u krinkov airsoft
handguard rail system for just 14.95 ooh
with a possibility of 4 interest
repayments and an epic badass foregrip
namely a kill house full-size airsoft
and paintball angled foregrip for only
29 canadian dollars and 25 canadian
cents so why does canadian ukrainian
volunteer put airsoft mods on his ak-74
rifle because it's an airsoft rifle
namely an avk airsoft cyma standard
stamped metal airsoft ak-47ueg rifle
with folding stuff and polymer furniture
only 223 on amazon oh look he even taped
his fake ak-47 magazines to it if only
he had done two minutes of research
beforehand by doing so he would have
found that the ak-74 is chambered for
nato's standard ammo 5.45 by 39
millimeter while the ak-47 is chambered
for soviet standard 7.62 by 39. the
magazine he taped there does not fit his
gun it's a different caliber this post
by kung flu panda actually got cuv so
triggered that he started pulling random
footage from telegram with the caption
look guys airsoft going through his
twitter feed it's obvious that he's just
pulling random war footage from other
people's accounts and posts them with
captions implying they're his own
footage
on one of his selfies he's wearing what
appears to be a mark 7 helmet standard
issue for british armed forces that it
is under the covering here it is again
and oh boy is it me or does that
cigarette look photoshopped okay let's
focus the helmet do you notice anything
strange about it oh that strap looks
awfully dangly there plastic buckle hmm
do mark 7 helmets really come with
plastic but no they don't they come with
a strap and a button do you know what
sort of mark 7 helmet comes with a
plastic buckle an airsoft replica which
can be yours for just 35 dollars
he's played carrier a condor gunner
retail version available for 71.95 his
bloody axe which i'm sure is drenched in
real russian blood and not just a
supermarket chicken breast is also a
commercially available amazon item his
headlamp famously useful for remaining
undetected during his much bragged about
nighttime operations is a cheap led that
he also got from amazon but canadian
ukrainian volunteer isn't just a
connoisseur of amazon ordered airsoft
gear the man also loves his badges
here we have him wearing a rhodesian sas
badge available for 7.99 by the way
rhodesia's state ceased to exist in
1979. the man does love his
religious-related decorational items
here's his rhodesian foreign legion
patch also available for 7.99 and here's
his ukrainian airborne assault patch
currently going for 950 on ebay and his
ukrainian airborne assault badge for
1790 but canadian ukrainian volunteer
just couldn't control himself on his
ebay shopping frenzy and also got a
world war ii french coming unit badge
for 37 dollars whatever floats your boat
i guess he also has two wagner group
patches on which she apparently spilled
some ketchup or something but according
to kung flu panda these would actually
be really hard to get outside of a
battlefield unless you have an internet
connection and eight dollars and five
cents to spend on ebay hey do you recall
this picture of the map with the badges
looks like someone discovered
sovietarystuff.com unable to control his
shopping courages maple syrup rambo
raided their stocks and purchased a
whole bunch of them all clean and
pristine by the way just like his amazon
ordered folding shovel which he claims
to be using to dig trenches with not a
single scratch after all that shoveling
this man takes excellent care of his
equipment and let's just stop and
consider canadian ukrainian volunteers
spent more than a thousand bucks on his
props all for his little twitter larp
session can you imagine what the
neighbors were thinking when they saw
him photographing himself in the
backyard with various knockoff military
gear lunch is ready god damn it mom i
told you not to bother me when i'm
outside taking my pictures all of this
is of course really sad where do you
have to be in your life to be larping on
twitter as a soldier with more than a
thousand bucks worth of props how sad
lonely and hungry for approval does one
have to be to do such thing but what the
ghost of ottawa doesn't realize is how
much harm he's actually doing with such
online exhibitionism do we remember his
post from the beginning mike filled me
in on the rats in the cellar mike
presumably being one of his imagery
friends their anguish sustains me the
more they squirm the harder i get so
this is his idea of sounding tough and
cool i guess i know because i've also
been 12 years old at one time but posts
like this are actually incredibly
harmful if it wasn't complete [ __ ]
written by sad and only 30 year old in
canada this post would imply that
foreign volunteers in ukraine are
committing war crimes by torturing
russian prisoners of war this is prime
material for russian propaganda which
can then use these posts to compel more
russians to enlist and join the war
which will lead to more suffering death
and destruction not to mention posts
like these discredit all the heroic men
and women ukrainians or volunteers who
are risking their lives on the front
line and not just cosplaying in their
garden to protect ukraine from russian
invasion and genocide for this dumbass
student just stumbled onto twitter and
pretend to be a volunteer and brag about
his imaginary war crimes is actually
quite disgusting but alas in the end
justice was served on the 2nd of july
the chairboard regiment lost its finest
man
canadian ukrainian volunteer was banned
off twitter good night sweet prince and
[ __ ] you seriously you're a goddamn
idiot dude don't do this ever again or
i'll have to talk to your parents and
for the rest of you thank you for
watching and don't forget to like and
subscribe and also check out my patreon
if you think this content is worth your
money and i'll be seeing you next time